I want to take you back to the year 2010
it's my senior year of high school and
I'm in the final round of a speech team
tournament yes I was the nerd in high
school who did speech team and
considered it a sport there are five of
the finalists in the room thirty people
there to watch just in three judges
sitting in the front row with their pins
and evaluation forms ready to go and I'm
there to give an eight minute speech on
a racial diversity so I deliver my
speech listening to my competitors do
the same gave them a cute little
applause and a fake smile and then we
all headed to the auditorium to hear the
final results and in first place they
announced JaJuan Jackson of course I
shared that story because I want you to
know how fabulous I am but really I
share that story because it was a moment
of pride back then but when I look back
on that moment today I'm not met with
pride I actually feel regret what I
didn't mention at the beginning of my
talk is that that speech wasn't
advocating for racial diversity I
essentially argued against it to be fair
I didn't say that diversity itself is
bad I just didn't understand the merits
of racial diversity in particular in
large part because I didn't understand
the full extent of racial inequity
reflecting on this moment I realized
that while I had strong communication
skills back then I lacked critical
consciousness a term coined by Paulo
Freire a Brazilian philosopher that
speaks to one's ability to critically
examine the world and do something to
change it realizing this inspired me to
help other youth especially underserved
youth build not just their communication
skills but also their critical
consciousness with the hope that they'll
be able to speak persuasively about
social justice but in doing this work
I've realized that critical
consciousness isn't just about
challenging what you say it's also about
challenging how you present yourself and
your ideas
now when I first started teaching public
speaking I did not realize this I used
to teach my students the control
framework and went a little something
like this
control your body stand up straight
relax your shoulders make sure they're
in line with your be gesture but not too
much control your voice speak up pace
yourself
Paul so that people really listen okay
not that long and enunciate every single
word as you speak now research shows
that if you do those behaviors you
actually do sound more persuasive but
the more I've been working with youth of
color and the more I've been reflecting
on my own public speaking style I
realize that there's a point when
control becomes conformity when the
right way to speak becomes the white way
to do it now let me be clear I don't
dislike the way that white people speak
I love y'all but it saddens me that we
have this unstated expectation that to
be heard you have to make yourself a
little too white majority culture maybe
that means cutting out the black
vernacular you learned at home because
it's not professional or maybe that
means limiting your expressions because
you were told you need to tone it down
or maybe it's cutting your afro like I
did in the 8th grade because you learned
that it's not presentable these
behaviors reflect the concept called
respectability politics when
marginalized people present themselves
in ways that are pleasing or respectable
to those with more privilege on the one
hand this makes complete sense our world
favors those who just fit in and as
important as authenticity is it comes
with a risk of being judged of being
ignored of being silenced and this is a
risk that many people care about not
just people of color according to a 2014
inclusion report from Deloitte 83% of
lesbian gay and bisexual people in the
u.s. said they are not bullied
themselves at work 66% of woman said the
same and so did 44% of straight white
men many of us feel this pressure took
to avoid the risk of exclusion but
conformity comes with a cost every time
we change how we present from the words
we use to our tone to our presentation
we validate a status quo that does not
equally appreciate multiple forms of
presentation we send a message to
younger generations that you can be
heard so long as you sound look and
dress more or less like everyone else
the easy answer would be or don't
conform when you communicate but it's
not that straightforward because at
times you do need to accommodate your
audience so that you can make your
perspective heard I don't know the
answer to to this question of how to
deal with that on the one hand I do want
to be authentic on the other hand I want
to be heard
even as I'm standing in front of you
right now I'm wondering if the way I'm
dressed in the way I'm presenting is
really me or just what I think you want
me to be and if I can't answer that
question for myself Who am I to talk to
my students about it one of my mentors
said you don't need to have the perfect
answer show on just open up the
conversation with your students so they
can critically engage with the topic so
now in one of my classes on public
speaking I'll read a series of
statements and ask students go to one
side if you agree another side if you
disagree and somewhere in the middle if
you're conflicted agree or disagree if I
were giving a speech in front of
politicians I would change my hair so
that I look more professional students
spread out across the entire room and
began to debate their opinions one of my
latina students said I'm not going to
straighten my curly hair because that's
a part of who I am
another student respectfully disagrees
and says it's not that big of a deal to
me so I'm gonna do it we don't come to a
perfect answer in that activity but
that's not the goal the goal is simply
to a question when a persuasion can be
problematic in the same activity I read
another statement agree or disagree to
make people care about a social issue I
will share a sad story about myself this
leads to a critical conversation about
storytelling too often we share those
sad stories so that people feel bad for
us and while those stories
can be moving they can often fall into
this trap of poverty porn you know what
that is those TV ads about those poor
little kids in Africa who needs your
donation that story about the boy named
Tony who grew up in Chicago in a
run-down apartment and a single-parent
home who would not make it in life
unless you donate to us nonprofit that's
Harvard porn storytelling is a powerful
tool of persuasion but the problem with
poverty porn is that it reduces your
humanities to the struggles you've
endured without critically examining the
narratives we're putting forward we risk
diluting our self-worth presenting an
incomplete picture of who we really are
that's a problem when I was teaching
public speaking last summer I had a
student who I won't soon forget Jose
he's a junior now Dominican American
incredibly smart and he dished about
half of my classes so one day I'm in the
hallway with him and I take him to the
side just to say what's going on he told
me he didn't like public speaking I
figured just about as much but his
reason why is what really got to me it
doesn't matter how much we speak up he
said at the end of the day rich white
people will always be in power
deep down I fear that Jose is right now
because rich white people will literally
always be in power but because if we're
not mindful of how we're presenting how
we're advocating for change we risk
changing the people in power believing
the culture largely the same so if I
were talking to younger so on today I
would tell them two things one you're
going to have that baby face for the
next ten years at least I'm sorry
it is what it is
and to and more importantly I would say
that it's not enough to change your
topic for that speech team competition
to argue for racial diversity instead of
against it you also need to critically
question how you're presenting yourself
in that room are you making yourself
conforming too much how far are you
willing to go and I want you want to
think about those questions as a
teenager because ten years later I want
him to feel free and comfortable to
speak his own truth the entire truth not
just because it will make me feel better
but because when you speak your truth
your whole truth
you empower everyone else around you to
do the same thank you
[Applause]
[Music]